today I want to tell you about a new
mobile app that's in development called
arc net which is part of a larger block
chain based augmented reality platform
called
CLIC Z and you can find out more about
both by clicking the link underneath
this video this video was sponsored by
click see and arc net and is not a
commentary about their token sale or any
financial aspect of the company and as I
say every time nothing in this video is
financial advice or investment advice
this is just an overview of the concept
behind the platform itself using only
publicly available information about the
company so as always every single viewer
should do their own research and due
diligence before making any financial
decision for themselves
so here is what arc net is looking to
accomplish with their platform you could
think about it almost as a kind of
pokemons go Meets Facebook and Yelp in a
sense so let's say you're walking around
with your smartphone you're either
walking by the Eiffel Tower in Paris or
you're walking by the San Diego Zoo or
the Statue of Liberty you probably
wouldn't walk by it maybe you're on a
boat going by the Statue of Liberty
using augmented reality through the arc
net app you would point your phone at
the landmark or the business or any kind
of establishment or noteworthy object
and on your screen you would see icons
called arcs hovering over the place the
store the monument whatever it is which
would give you a lot of different
information about what you're looking at
you'd be able to see things like what's
the establishment called what is the
establishment offer reviews whether they
have free Wi-Fi if they're offering a
coupon pictures of products that are
available for sale and the advantage
would be that you could call any of this
up instantly without having to even
figure out the name of the place
figuring out the address or looking up
their website or their Facebook page or
any other information it would just be a
matter of pointing and tapping on the
store through augmented reality using
the camera that's already on your phone
it would even be possible to use arcnet
for various things within an
establishment so imagine you're at a
museum and each exhibit might have its
own arc which would contain more
information or videos about what it is
that you are looking at and there would
even be arcs at businesses that serve as
virtual mailboxes through which the
business can communicate with the public
as an example arcs could be created for
homes that are for sale or for rent
you're shopping for a house you pull up
to the house you could use arc net to
see pictures and videos of the inside
and information about the property for
example arcs could be created for
special events like a conference or a
reunion or for advertising if you're
walking by a billboard or an ad on the
subway you could look at arcs on the ads
that would give you more information
about the brand the users of the arc net
platform would be able to add arcs to
anything so arcs would always be getting
added to the database collaboratively so
that you're not always relying on a
centralized source or the establishment
themselves which could be providing
biased or arbitrary information that
makes it more of a social media type of
experience you could also make the arcs
public or private which lets you control
who is able to see them and arcs would
be monetizable in different ways as well
as being able to buy sell and trade arcs
one other component would be that
anybody using the app would have their
own arc net social media profile which
other users would be able to see
hovering over you in augmented reality
on their own arc net app if you want and
of course you would have full control
over what isn't isn't visible on your
profile you could follow other profiles
you could grow a following on arc net so
this is a very interesting concept I've
been interested in augmented reality for
a long time it's been taking off to some
degree over the last few years and there
are a lot of new apps and games
incorporating augmented reality to
different degrees there are major
electronics and software companies that
are
in the stages of rolling out augmented
reality products or will be doing so
soon so there seems to be a real
possibility that augmented reality will
have a much bigger role in social media
and in entertainment in the future and
an implementation like the one that arc
net is looking to do is a really
interesting step in that direction one
that will be fascinating to follow and I
look forward to seeing how the platform
develops like I said you can learn more
about arc net by clicking the link
underneath this video check it out
today's show was sponsored in part by EE
which you can check out by clicking the
link underneath this video it's a crypto
currency investing in trading platform
that uses artificial intelligence to
trade Kryptos on your behalf
getting started is really easy on the EE
website choose your preferred crypto
enter your wallet address Bitcoin
litecoin etherium - Bitcoin cash are all
options EE says there will be more in
the near future minimum deposit is as
low as point zero zero for Bitcoin which
is great if you want to test out the
site without making a major commitment
financially you can choose from many
different trading package options with
different timelines deposits or instant
payouts are processed within 24 hours on
weekdays with a minimum withdrawal of
only point zero zero - Bitcoin
everything goes straight to your crypto
wallet address you can also make 5 to 15
percent Commission's from w's referral
program you can easily make payments
track your daily interest track your
referral commissions by connecting your
telegram account to double e's telegram
bot which makes for an even more
streamlined experience on ee ee says
they protect all deposits with daily
updated DDoS protection and global CDN
acceleration ee says their goal is to
make crypto trading accessible for
average people even people with small
crypto holdings you can get started and
join thousands of other users by
clicking the link underneath this video
and as always this is not financial
advice everyone should understand that
there are inherent risks with any kind
of investing always do your own
research before using any method of
trading or investing in crypto
currencies and never invest more than
you are willing to lose